[Music]
in know what news submitted but I don't
feel so good
mr. stark spider-man will no longer be
important to marvel cinematic you oh
yeah Cinematic Universe that's right how
could they do this to us
that's what's been going on in the
internet for the past couple days wait
why I'm concerned me and Sony okay could
not reach a co-financing agreement why
can't you just get along you [ __ ]
Sony wanna go [ __ ] the fans they
couldn't wait to spread the fans legs
and start [ __ ] them again cuz they
got tired of all this Marvel [ __ ] doing
really well they couldn't wait to put
their fists up their [ __ ] face like
that wait dude this or this wait there's
Sony oh and it's a woman's fault somehow
- I don't get it what the woods actually
who get who do stuff the Marvel deal Amy
Pascal so Marvel Marvel owns spider-man
right Sony owns spider-man but Sonia was
licensing that to Marvel so are to
Disney so that because shoot the whole
Marvel Cinematic Universe dummy Marvel
doesn't own spider but Sony was paying
for [ __ ] everything you know that
Sony was paying for the production of
everything then they were sweating a
portion of it was a 30 percent 5 percent
of first-dollar gross okay yeah and then
they were about the top merchandise
revenue okay
so right so now they wanted to do 50%
they come back 50/50 Dizzy's like hey we
want 50% and Sony's like weak we're
still gonna be paying for this [ __ ] and
[ __ ] you guys but Disney also wants them
to co-financed 50 52 5050 in the
beginning 50 50 at the end yeah yeah
spend and make Disney Disney wanted that
where's Marvel in all of this well
Disney owns Marvel Marvel's is the IP
did you know the Clintons used to own
Marvel for a minute mm-hmm
she's made aunts just like oh did you
guys hear yeah would they do with it the
[ __ ] glasses I'm talking is I forgot
who but it was a whole documentary made
on it was like oh they were they owned
the marbles in [ __ ] what's-his-name
Stanley tried to buy it back and he
didn't own his own company ah and then
something else happened and then I was
like damn that's kind of shady I think
it was like a Michael Moore think or
documentary or I forgot what it was can
you tell my life story at my funeral for
me yeah lots of facts yeah I just I just
thought bits and pieces of
misinformation that would be the history
that I'd give I want a stripper to do
with the boobs yeah I'm not a stripper
but I can help
a little yes no buts your funeral right
so maybe I'll have three people like
just doing this while I speak that's
pretty good endo might match my cadence
you know I met her maybe three years ago
I think it was six yeah I think she's 24
wait when I met her I think they always
get the same age that I was playing an
instrument
they'll be entertained though so that's
all that matters I can't even remember
ever tell me about you guys aren't
taking this very seriously this
spider-man shit's going down oh yeah I
heard there's a big fire somewhere but I
don't give a [ __ ] though not by the
spider-man we will be talking about that
I don't want to talk about that I heard
it's on in the Amazon but I don't give a
[ __ ] because I wanted about spider-man
nurdrage is the best I know
yep so that's why everyone's freaking
out right now worried about it in the
world but you know what I am also
concerned Joe they set up spider-man to
be the centerpiece of the MCU don't know
now what's how can they take that away
there's gonna be some shitty venom movie
cliffhangers to that like how are they
gonna resolve it which I did you see
part of them
I thought was it good I think Tom wons a
great spy he's a great spider-man I
thought the movie was fun yeah I had fun
what about I've seen it was the first
ones homecoming yeah homecoming was good
I like homecoming we'll see don't take
this away from me it's all I live for it
I don't have anything else going for me
yeah so people are like saying like on
Twitter a Sony literate in all caps
literally literally took spider-man away
from us just after we witness the
biggest cliffhanger what so everyone's
blaming Sony yes is everyone blaming
Sonja yes Marvel or Disney no so there
is there is a lot of the portion of the
blame is going to Disney as well because
they're saying like come on Disney why
couldn't you negotiate why did it have
to be heard that's two out of ten people
though everyone else is [ __ ] all
over sunny because Sony sucked at making
their movies sony sony didn't come back
with a counter whatever they just read
like nope [ __ ] it we're out yeah they
didn't even counter offer whatever then
this other tweet was like I think it's
cool that Sony is carrying on its
tradition of completely [ __ ] uh
spider-man 3 hey you know what they made
spider-man 1 and 2 and those are [ __ ]
amazing movies I don't know [ __ ] but
spider-verse absolutely one well they
made that too how about that ok fine
then I don't know how I feel about this
or that the animation people did that
the animation people in charge of the
movie yeah cuz [ __ ] they did a good job
I don't know [ __ ] about film some city
oh okay so you don't have to know [ __ ]
nobody knows [ __ ] we all these words and
[ __ ] and I'm just like words I look i
watch netflix didn't you just say that
yeah you watch netflix all day so what's
wrong with that you have a take I don't
you know what I like to make films and
write and stuff but the more someone
knows about film I hate them cuz I'm
like you're a nerd you don't have a life
what the [ __ ] get the [ __ ] away from me
thank you
no it's good for me because I don't have
a nerd they don't look at me it's good
because I'm easily amused then because
you can tell me whatever [ __ ] I'm
like that's [ __ ] dope but then like
Casey and steel really your [ __ ]
you're an idiot see I'm a good person
ever around if I don't know anything
mwah ya know yeah
we'll see there's a difference between
creators and audience people and the
complaining our audience people I'd
rather talk to you than half the people
in all I wouldn't who have their sticks
up their asses about don't you off I
will compliment anything that you guys
tell me it's fine I'm not here to be
your positive light so you never seen
anything in the MCU like own ask
yourself am see you like I was never a
big spider-man person for some reason I
just know Tobey Maguire the face yeah I
don't know spider-man makes anybody
horny from this like that people you
know yeah for makes people horny yeah
Loki fan Loki can lock woman makes
people horny yes you know
Aquaman never see that I see that yeah I
heard that that movie isn't even shot in
the water they just shoot underneath the
chicks chair why do they gotta lie to us
man stays well I was wondering why they
don't have to use something
Hollywood's just a bunch of lies yeah so
I mean I guess you don't really care
that Avenger I'm not I'm like I'm on the
same but it's never what does that mean
to that universe like they're gonna
continue to make their movies without
what does it mean to the people that do
care just the movies aren't gonna come
out this is our culture already supposed
to come and he was booked for two movies
already like in the future so people are
like he's such an integral part what how
integral integral part of the MCU right
now because of everything that happened
like with Ironman now the Ironman diet
and all that stuff he died you didn't
know this [ __ ] okay it's been a while
divorced no end game and game audion
watch end game but now I know I remember
my father minutes been like the year
like the end of Game of Thrones or this
time - isn't that crazy and they both
have starts in it oh that's sure that's
right the government up to now yeah true
the next president is gonna be something
stark stark there yo well yeah I don't
know I mean yeah I think if you're a fan
though I could see why you get heated
cuz imagine like like let's say you know
that once though I don't watch season 2
us but when Jon Snow gets stabbed oh
dude I was he's dead and then everyone's
like [ __ ] what do we do now the lead of
this entire series is dead and then
because of some executive producer
[ __ ] and studio [ __ ] hey we
gotta shut down camera Thrones I can see
a fat my fans throwing a fit so I
understand I mean I just not that
connected to spider-man so I don't
really care about that but I could see
why people are [ __ ] but imagine they
imagine they don't kill Jon Snow yeah
Jon Snow is the centerpiece of this
whole [ __ ] show and then all of a
sudden they pull Johnson or the show and
they're like yeah don't worry about it
he gets his own show right he's on his
own show now with licensed characters
who are in the like completely different
imagine if Jon Snow got into Lord of the
Rings
yes fell through that so I'm a big fan
of kick boxer right look mantlet Van
Damme and he's a kickboxer one kickboxer
- same story
Van Dam's gone some [ __ ] another
weird white guy that does martial arts
man the kickboxer 3 4 5 it's not the
same it's the world is in the vein of
kick box but it's not the same people
think he becomes guile on Street Fighter
what yeah I was so pissed when I was
like 10 and 11 that's what happened to
me when I was watching this movie called
the substitute with Tom Berenger yeah
great movie - he's a he's an ex-marine
and he comes to a school of like
Dangerous Minds kids oh no [ __ ] you yeah
and he's like throwing kids out of
windows and [ __ ] teaching respect yeah
and then the second movie they replace
him with treat Williams whoa who is this
candy ass mother fee
and then by the fourth movie with treat
Williams I was like this guy's a badass
because he kills the whole football team
I get the same effect with the kickboxer
series oh I know
I never earn my respect to live bad damn
did I get it you didn't do this with
that's the only I think of whenever I
think of vendhya and plus he was a damn
it yeah that's all I know a wonderful
dancer dance
there's not one see what movie was that
kickboxer it was dancing while kicking
people's asses while doing the splits
yeah I'll be perfect on this next
upcoming a couple of movies they've
announced for Marvel I just I had no
familiarity with so I'm not that excited
like running out of characters yeah
Frank she's one of them I know yeah and
whatever the means but I don't [ __ ]
know that around like Hawkeye and yeah
the four who knows cuz like guard Alex
is no one really widow who died so now
whatever you gonna do it's a prequel I'm
like I don't care about prequels yeah
but no one knew guardians of the galaxy
but they were they [ __ ] awesome that
was amazing guardians well I'm waiting
for them to come out so that I can watch
them and get excited about what I'm not
excited about this it's hard seeing I
was reading this one article that
because of Tycho itt's newest movie with
a jojo rabbit how he like portrays
Hitler and like a comedic way yeah like
an imaginary friend a little kid that
yeah so they're saying that they were
saying like Disney might like reconsider
having take a direct garden why I mean
Disney worked with Nazis sorry it was
thorne oh man thorne
yeah I don't know cuz I was like what no
he did so good with Ragnarok there was a
little bit of not scene they were like
yeah cuz you know how they did it yeah
oh they worked with Nazi stuff though
that's why they're so probably like they
don't wanna talk like what are they
trippin about the projecting didn't
Steamboat Mickey help the Nazis I
thought I heard something that I'm sure
like I heard that was a what's the word
urban legend no yeah absolutely it's
like complete truth like I don't know
that's a rumor and in
you went way too deep I know with a
cartoon there was a cartoon that was
made but it wasn't officially there
there's a bootleg
[Music]
[Music]